Sicario day of the Soldado is directed
by Stefano sollima not the knee
Villeneuve who directed the first film
and this film is about the ongoing fight
against terrorism and drug cartels and
in this case we get to watch Brolin and
del Toro try to stop people who are
secretly assisting terrorists in
crossing the border illegally the first
film I thought was very unique extremely
bleak it didn't have a nice Hollywood
ending it felt like a downer you know it
wasn't like you left the theater excited
or happy but it was so well directed and
very well written by Taylor Sheridan who
returns to write this film but by far
the most surprising aspect of that first
film was Alejandro played by del Toro
and it was so nice to find out they
would make a second one featuring his
character because he stole the entire
first film and once again this character
is such a draw del Toro plays him so
wonderfully and he's a character that
although he has a moral Center he's
certainly not a good guy he will kill
children if he needs to he'll torture
people he'll go outside of the law to
get answers for things that happened to
him in the past but also for trying to
protect the country he lives in and the
same goes for Brolin who is far more
intense in this film than he was in the
last in an opening scene he's
interrogating someone and he threatens
to bomb their entire family's house if
this person doesn't answer questions and
you can tell he's not bluffing these
aren't the good guys these are the
characters that try to get things done
that no one else wants to do and you
don't necessarily root for them you just
sort of sit back in awe at the things
they have to do the action sequences are
not helmed from an entertainment point
of view I hesitate to even refer to them
as action sequences really they're just
scenes in which violence occurs and it's
always depicted in a way that makes you
feel as if you're there the violence
happens so quick it's so brutal and it's
extremely efficient but it doesn't come
off as entertainment like shove popcorn
in your face and watch these horrific
things happen it's a film that has a
message and just like Taylor Sheridan's
directorial effort winDriver
that film had a very heart wrench
message about the way Native Americans
are treated today and how they've been
treated for a long time and how terrible
it is and this film decides to focus on
what happens to children who are caught
in the middle of terrorist acts or the
drug world many scenes throughout the
film highlight this an early one at a
supermarket that's just horrific and
then throughout the film there's a very
common through line with two young
people one boy who's sort of being
groomed to be an assassin or at least be
involved in the drug trade in some way
and then a young girl who gets taken but
it's not that she's just kidnapped by
the bad guys
she's very much so a pawn and some
people are gonna have a problem with
this but this is in my opinion a very
realistic portrayal of some of the
terrible things that go on in the world
and it's not shown in a way as I said
for entertainment purposes and I
guarantee there will be a lot of critics
who have a tough time with this movie
because it is very dark and it is very
grim and I have a feeling that some
critics are going to let their
viewpoints on things perhaps get in the
way of this movie and not quite
understand the message taylor Sheridan
is trying to communicate how war
terrorism and drugs has a terrible
effect on children and I think that
message really comes through in the end
especially in an absolutely mind-blowing
final scene that did not go the way I
thought it would that's something this
film does extremely well it always
sidesteps your normal Hollywood
convention of how you would expect a
scene to go when something occurs it's
almost like you can kind of guess how
they're going to get out of it or what
the end result will be and in almost
every scenario the scene ended
differently I'm just so glad that
Benicio del Toro has his own franchise
now and I'm also really glad that
despite the fact that this does not have
one of my favorite directors Denis
Villeneuve helming it with Taylor shared
and staying on as a writer it remains a
nice companion piece with that first
movie it's not quite as good just simply
because I think Villeneuve and Roger
Deakins crafted such a gorgeously almost
perfectly edited film the first time
around but as a story this second one is
actually a lot more complex than the
first Sicario which i rewatched
yesterday
the first film has a very simple story
really it's basically this one agent
played by Emily Blunt experiencing the
dark drug cartel world and she finds out
there are some secrets it's really a
very basic story that was just elevated
by some incredible filmmaking Sicario to
is is far more complex really it shows
the effect on children
it shows the moral dilemma that the good
guys face when they're trying to get
answers and it does so in a way that
does not come off as popcorn
entertainment it comes off as a
disturbing exploration of the fact that
sometimes there are no good guys there's
just two sides that are both trying to
go for different goals one of them is a
little more selfish than the other and
one has the goal of eventually
protecting people in a country but from
both sides you can understand that it's
just kind of a gray area and this film
explores that gray area that a lot of
films don't have the balls to explore
I'm gonna give Sicario day of the
Soldado and a - guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon I did see ant-man
and the wasp I'll have that review to
you guys soon thank you very much and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]